il fallait voir aussi dans envoyé
spécial sur france 2 c'était joli parce
qu'on n'était pas là vendredi donc
forcément on a dû remonter jusqu'à jeudi
c'est un imbroglio où l'on pouvait pas
savoir
on est tombé sur un homme qui a fait le
buzz après son interwiew regarder il a
poussé un coup de gueule contre l'école
à domicile
c'est vrai que l'école à domicile ça a
été une panne a souligné m franchement
elle est mec moi il ya des adf
franchement il ya des problèmes de maths
et où j'étais à la c1 mais je te le dire
ouais mais heureusement que j'avais
correction je faisais mito comme ça je
regarde et qu'on attendait lino ils en
sont là c'est exactement in hope alive
again à 8 ans il en prépa chaussée
attendait tous les élèves
comme tous les jours de tournage du
ballon rond c'est au bar c'est bien vous
voulez calé sur le cp oui à 8 ans il en
cp ouais parce que en fait j'ai pris le
programme de cp parce que je m'en
sortais pas que je n'attaquais pas
tempère pas quand ces pétards mais
c'était déjà les dents les amateurs ont
commandé plus de 12000 c'est un merci
super mamerow seulement à manger des
frites
merci si non je ne vis pas attendre les
résultats
mais c'est difficile à l'école à la
maison c'est difficile à l'école à la
maison c'est difficile il faut imprimer
imprimés imprimés acheter les quartiers
de cartouches des poux le débit on est
comme des campus dingue comme il est en
cours c'est un budget et il a raison
c'est vrai imprimés imprime à imprimer
et moi moi moi chez moi j'ai fait mon
brouillé cli profile lui imprimer il
faut acheter même de rentrer en compte
t'as pas d' ipad n'a pas de téléphones
windows ne peut pas faire la
visioconférence et ben oui oui t'as pas
d'ordinateur comme la serbie chez elle
sans rigoler irin que pendant le
confinement une des ventes qui a explosé
de vente par correspondance sur internet
c'est l'imprimante
à bercy on n'a pas d'imprimante à
l'anoci enfin voila moi j'ai jamais eue
d'aprimo et là maintenant vous en avez
une mais pas du tout qui n'a pas
d'ordinateur
la magasin de rythme un gma pas
d'ordinateur pas ce que tu as dit j'ai
heureusement vous avez des petites mains
vous venez d fous mais il met en scène
un vol d'oiseau aux ailes en art et non
mais vraiment c'est vous c'est vrai ça
ouais c'est d'ailleurs franchement
c'était une période dure et c'est encore
une période dure mais faut tirer quand
même un coup de chapeau aux gens qu'on
réussit à faire tout en visio et tous
les enseignants mais c'est vrai que
c'est dur les nichoirs des imprimantes
serait que ceux des sous j'aurais
peut-être parce que peut-être la
connerie que j'ai fait ça m'excite
peut-être pas ton peut-être pas ton
rougir et laisser sécher voilà dans des
six mais j'ai bien aimé mais on voyait
que la tunisie est un truc tu aurais pu
dire la même chose si je t'avais dit que
tu portes du slip de bain se sentait pas
trop sûrs d'eux et tu vois tout oui lady
chatterley
oui non je disais que sa crème était un
grand élan de solidarité parce qu'elle
est grande ancien l'impression qu'ils
ont reçu les mails de toutes les
familles qui n'avaient pas d'imprimante
et qu'ils déposaient sous la porte faute
tous les prospectus feintool et les
traits dont avaient besoin les élèves et
ça a été du bénévolat pendant ces deux
mois et c'est super fun elle est là la
changer pour le cours d'un virus alors
ils sont rigolos et de l'info les mecs
reviennent d'un fournil en de la graine
l épave sur arte et des tout-petits
contient bon boulot et tout ce que vous
avez résumé des deux mois de
télé-enseignement s'éprennent de
cartouches d'imprimantes c'est ce truc
vous avez retenu vous des deux mois mais
qu'est ce qu'on a retenu je vous disais
moi j'ai retenu sa berline corps est
positif pour rendre compte que les
parents se rendent compte que les
devoirs des ombres on sait pas si facile
que drake quand ils bossent sur des
mauvaises bas c'est pas si facile pour
un écho à ce qu'on a tendance à dire
vas-y moi aussi j'ai passé le bac c is
it c'est maintenant c'est pas si simple
que ça me rassure c'est pas ici c'est
pas ici et des gamins compas
l'imprimante expliquait en effet la
prison me gêne de tous leurs copains
france ce dimanche à valence est alors
ils vous avaient redoublé ses mots et
ses vins j'ai commencé très tôt à
redoubler c'est super